اوقاتكم اهلا بكم الى اخبار الساعه
نبداوها في ابرز العناوين
الايرانيه ضد المحتاجين تحت المجهرات
تشكيل لجنه امميه للتحقيق والمحاسبه
تفاجات المونديال مستمره البرتغال
تتجاوز غانا بصعوبه والاعين على نتيجه
البرازيل وصربيا
رغم اللقاء الامريكي بقصد للتهدئه الاكراد
يشعرون بالخضلان وتركيا تواصلها هجماتها
شمال سوريا
بعد زيارته شغل مثيره للجدل لبكيير رئيس
المجلس الاوروبي يحمل اجنده حساسه الى
الصين الاسبوع المقبل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم هل انتهاكات خطيره الارقام صادمه
الوضع مقلق وخطير هذا ما اجمع عليه
المشاركون في اجتماع مجلس حقوق الانسان في
جنيف حول انتهاكات النظام الايراني بحق
المحتجين مفوض الامم المتحده اسامي لحقوق
الانسان
كاعرب عن قلقه من الوضع خصوصا بالنسبه
لحالات اعدام المحتاجين وقال ان اربعه عشر
الف شخص اعتقلوا منذ بدء الى احتجاجات
فيما قتل اكثر من 300 بينهم 40 بينهم 40
طفلا و 20 امراه من جهته راى المحقق
الامني الخاص في ايران ان الوضع في
المناطق الكرديه
وخرج اجتماعهم مجلس حقوق الانسان بقرار
الموافقه على تشكيل لجنه تقصي حقائق حول
انتهاكات النظام الايراني ضد المحتاجين
تمهيدا لمحاسبته
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مين
مشاهد الاطفال الذين يقتلون وصور النساء
التي يتم ضربهم في الشوارع والاشخاص
المحكومين بالاعدام راينا موجات من
الاحتجاجات في ايران خلال السنوات الماضيه
او التي تنادي بالعداله والمساواه
والكرامه واحترام الحقوق الانسان وقبلت
بالعمق والقمع واستعمال القوه المبالغ
فيها وغير الضروريه يجب ان تتوقف العقليه
القديمه لاصحاب السلطه في مجابهه
الاحتجاجات لانها لا تنفع على العكس تفاقم
من الاوضاع نحن الان نواجه ازمه على اعلى
المستويات على الصعيد حقوق الانسان في
ايران
التحرك الامميه رافقه تحركنا امريكيه ايضا
حيث قلى وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطون
بلانكين ان بلاده ستواصله دعم الشعب
الايراني في مواجهه قمع السلطات الوحشي
وفق تعبيره وادعم لين كان لها السلطات
الايرانيه لوقف قمع المحتاجين والعنف ضد
النساء والفتيات مشيرا الى عمل بلاده على
اقصاء ايران من لجنه الامم المتحده
المعنيه بحقوق المراه
من باريس معنا المحلل السياسي طارق وهبي
طارق اهلا بك يعني هذا ما تحدث عنه وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه ان بلاده تعمل على طرد
ايران من لجنه الامم المتحده المعنيه
بحقوق المراه كيف سنعكس ذلك على الوضع هذا
القرار هل سيؤثر بالفعل همم على همم
النظام الحاكم في ايران
مساء الخير يا سيدي وشكرا للاستضافه يعني
كل ما يحصل داخل مؤسسه الامم المتحده
وخصوصا ما نسميه يعني العمل على احراج
ايران والعمل على تطويق ايران بكل ما
نسميه الممارسات الغير انسانيه
وبالتحديد خارج نطاق حقوق الانسان منذ
السادس عشر من سبتمبر ايلول الماضي كل ذلك
يعني مبني على فكره مهمه هو تطبيق ايران
بعد كل ما قامت به
الكم التي كانت تطلبه داخل ما نسميه
الاتفاق النووي الان اصبح لدى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وكل الفرقاء التي كانت
تنادي لايران لكي تكمل يعني
قليلا بكل ما تطلبه ان يكون هناك تعاطي
اخر وها نحن الان امام نسميه حركه مقابله
تقوم بها الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وايضا تقوم بها يعني
هنا طلبوا داخل مجلس يعني هذه الحركه سيد
طارق هل هي رفع عتب ام ماذا يعني اليوم
الايرانيون على الاقل في الداخل يريدون
تحركا دوليه يحميهم
صحيح في في العلاقات الدوليه ليست رفع عتب
في العلاقات الدوليه هي تكادث له علاقه
بالمفهوم القانوني له علاقه بمفهوم الى اي
مدى الدول تستطيع ان تعطي لايران ولغير
ايران نوعا ما انذارات لها علاقه
بالرجوع عن كل هذه الاخطاء التي ترتكب في
الداخل ولكن بنفس الوقت معك حق ان تقول ان
الشعب الايراني يطلب من المؤسسه الدوليه
ويطلب من الشعوب ومن الدول ان تقف الى
جانب ما نسميه هذا المطالب التي لها علاقه
بالحريه التي لها علاقه
بالخروج من ما نسميه حكم الملالي ولكن
بنفس الوقت الملالي في الداخل يقولون انها
مؤامره يقولون ان هناك همم دفع عدد كبير
من الاموال هناك همم وضع تصرف مثلا نوع من
الانترنت الخاص للاتصالات الذي له علاقه
في الشباب وحتى المعارضه الايرانيه في همم
في فرنسا وحتى في الخارج تحديد تقول ان
هناك ارقام همم مخيفه لها علاقه بالسجون
الشباب المسجون ان كان الشباب الرجال
والنساء يعني وهذا خطر جدا ولكن بنفس
الوقت هذه حركه انطلقت وهذه الحركه انا
باعتقادي لن تستطيع ايران ان توقفها وبنفس
الوقت يجب على الدول عامه ان تتلقى هذه
الرساله وان تذهب مثل حضرتك بامور ليست
فقط كلاميه ولكن بتفعيل هذه الامور التي
اعتقد انها تكون نوعا ما جزاء لايران
ولذلك عبر هذه المؤسسه التي لها علاقه
بحقوق الانسان ستقوم المانيا وايسلندا
برفع هذا الطلب وباعتقاده الاثنين سيكون
هناك واضح تقرير يدين ايران في هذا
الموضوع ويطلب من الامين العام للامم
المتحده القيام او وضع خطه
لمساعده هؤلاء الذين يعني يعني اليوم تسج
ميران او تقتلهم ايران وخصوصا ان الوضع
اصبح خطيرا لانه تدخل الحرس الثوري مباشره
في بعض الامور في مناطق معينه يعطيك الى
اي مدى هناك خطوره بمفهوم الامن القومي او
الامن الذي
يكمش على ايران او الذي بيده همم
شكرا جزيلا للمحلل السياسي طارق وهبي كنت
معنا من باريس
[موسيقى]
امام كل تصعيد من النظام الايراني لقمه
الاحتجاجات يقابله تصعيد من نوع اخر من
قبل المحتجين على الطرق تنوعتهما وتعبيرا
فمن همم مسيرات والاضرابات في الاسواق الى
الاحتجاج احتجاج طلاب الجامعات ليصلها
الان الى اطلاق دعوات لاستقاله النواب
قامت مجموعه من الكتاب في محافظه كردستان
بدعوه البرلمانيين الى استقاله جماعيه
تضامنا مع ما وصفتها بالشعب الحزين
معتبرين ان الناس عبرت عن غضبها بسبب
الفقر المقطع وكثره الفساد والظلم والقسوه
العنانيه للحكام والقمه
بلاش الدنيا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
منذ انطلاق الاحتجاجات في ايران لم تتوقف
التقارير الغربيه بالتحدث عن اساليب
النظام القمعيه تجاه المتظاهرين لكن صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه وطبقا لنتائج
تحقيقاتها لمقاطع فيديو متعلقه
بالاحتجاجات كشفت وجه جديد لقوات النظام
التي تقوم باستخدام سيارات الاسعاف للتسلل
الى التجمعات واعتقال المتظاهرين في دوره
اكد متحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه
ان التسلل قوات الامن في سيارات الاسعاف
لاعتقال المتظاهرين يظهر مدى خوف المرشد
الايراني من شعبه
[موسيقى]
تتجه الانذار الان لمباراه البرازيل
وصربيا في نهايه الجوله الاولى لكاس
العالم هذا المونديال الذي يحمل المفاجات
كثيره منذ بدايته شهد تفوقا لافتا
لمنتخباتي اسيا بالنسبه لنتائج اليوم
البرتغال بقياده كريستيانو رونالدو
بصعوبه بثلاثه اهداف مقابل هدفين في منتزع
المنتخب الكوري الجنوبي نقطه ثمينا من
الاوروغواي بعد تعادل سلبي وشاهده الجوله
الاولى ادام قويه للمنتخبات الاسيويه امام
منتخبات كبرى مرشحه للفوز بكاس العالم
وحصلت عليه سابقا تبدا غدا الجوله الثانيه
من دوري المجموعات في كاس العالم بلقاء
يضم قطر
معانا من الدوحه من منطقه الجماهير الخاصه
بالفيفا منفذ العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي
عبد المحسن الاوضاع عندك اليوم والبرازيل
الان تلعبوا باكر قطر شنو الاجواء 00
للحين البرازيل
نعم بالفعل عاطل
00 حتى الان الكل متخوف المشجعين المنتخب
البرازيلي في هذه المنطقه احيانا النتائج
التي حققتها الفرق قبل ايام تحدث عن
اليابان والسعوديه عندما انتصرنا سويها
على الارجنتين والمانيا حتى الان البرازيل
تواجه منتخب الاقل
كثير منها ولكن حتى الان
تشير الى التعادل ربما يكون هناك مفاجاه
اخرى لاخر مباراه في الجوله الاولى في
المونديال وتفوز صربيا او حتى تتعادل
وتعثر
التي تريد ان في هذه النسخه ان تصل الى
مراحل متقدمه جدا خصوصا وانها
خطيره يا جماعه
الباب تحدث من خبراء كره القدم بانها هذه
هؤلاء اللاعبين من منتخب البرازيلي هي
افضل نسخه للمنتخب البرازيلي حصلت منذ
ربما 20 سنه ماضيه ولكن عادل هنالك حاله
عجيبه في همم او ليست مستغربه في حقيقه في
في بادي الامر او في في هذه البطوله
تحديدا تواجد همم الجماهير الجزائريه
بكثره الجزائر هذا العام لا تشارك ولكن
جمهورها متواجد هنا لمؤازره كافه
المنتخبات العربيه ماهي احد همم مشجعين
الجزائريين حدثني عن هذه السنه الجزائر لا
تشارك في هذه البطوله ولكن شاهدت كثير
الجزائريه تمثل في تواجدكم الكثير من
الدول العربيه
الدول العربيه احنا تونس والمغرب اخوته
المغرب وتونس
نعم عبد المحسن يبدو
ان هناك خلل من المصدر يا عبد المحسن ما
نحن وياك طيب عبد المحسن رجع مره ثانيه
[موسيقى]
نسلم عليها المباشر شكرا
جمهور جزائري والمغرب يسويه ويعذران بعضهم
البعض الجمهور العربي بشكل عام يشعر بخطر
بانه همم كتله واحده يحتاج لان يعذر بعضه
البعض وايضا في انتصار السعوديه الاخير
كان هناك تكاثف عرض بشكل مباشر جدا كبير
يعني لا مبالغ عندما اقول بانه الكثير من
الجمهور العربي هنا متفائل لدرجه كبيره
بعد انتشار الاخضر ربما ان شاء الله همم
اتصالات عربيه
بالنسبه للمغرب وتونس ونقول لهم ان شاء
الله مربوحه وبالنسبه ربعنا سواء السعوديه
ولا قطر ان شاء الله نقول الوعد قدام
رايحين شكرا لان اللي عبد المحسن الحربي
من منطقه الجماهير الخاصه
مثلت بطوله كاس العالم التي تجرى حاليا في
قطر نسخه تتالق حراس المرمى في المباريات
الاولى التي اجريت الى الان ضمن دور
المجموعات خاصه في الدقائق الاخيره نجعل
منتخباتهم
تستفيد من صدهم للمحاولات تماما مثل ما
فعل الحارس السعودي محمد العويس انه تابع
التقرير التاليه الذي استعرض اسماء ابرز
الحراس الذين تالقوا في المونديال في قطر
حتى الان
في كره القدم عاده يقاس اداء كل فريق
بالاهداف المسجله فالاضواء كلها تسلط على
المهاجمين اكثر من غيرهم في مونديال قطر
كسرت القاعده الحسابات الرياضيه اعدت وفق
معادله جديده سعرها حراس المرمى الذين
تحولوا الى ارقام ثابته
في صد الكره في لقاء السعوديه والارجنتين
حارس الاخضر السعودي محمد العويس وضع
قاعده جديده تقول ان كل كره تصدها بمثابه
هدف في مرمى الخصم وفق هذه القاعده وقف
جدارا انكسرت امامه هجمات الاسطوره ميسي
ورفاقه العويس تحول الى عريس في مباراه
للتاريخ حارس مرمى الكمبيوتر الياباني
عطل الماكينه الالمانيه ومنح فريقه فوزا
لم يتوقعه احد البلجيكي
ضربه جزاء امام كندا واوقف كل المحاولات
ليظفر ورفاقه باول ثلاث نقاط في المونديال
المكسيكي جولر لم يكن اقل شانا تمكن من
تحويل ركله جزاء امام بولندا الى مجرد
فرصه رائعه ومنح فريقه تعادل يزن ذهب
المغربي ياسين بونو وتونسي ايمن دحمان
برزه بشكل لافت ايضا الفصول الاخيره من
مباريات البطوله الجاريه يكتبها حراس
المرمى ليعلن انفسهم نجوما ساطعه في سماء
المونديال العربيه
[موسيقى]
الكل تالق عدا حارس كوستاريكا اذن لدينا
في اخبار الساعه
اوروبا تفشل في تحديده سقف سعر الغاز لكن
تتفق على حزمه عقوبات جديده ضد روسيا
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله شكوكو كثيره تدور حول موعد
العمليه البريه التي اعلنت تركيا عن نيتها
القيام بها في شمالي سوريا تقارير اعلاميه
تركيه تحدثت عن الموعد المحتمل للهجوم
البري سيكون في شهر ديسمبر المقبل بعد
انتهاء عمليه المقلب شمالي العراق
من الدوائر الحكوميه التركيه
بريه اكبر بكثير في سوريا
[موسيقى]
معنى من اسطنبول مراسل العربيه زيدان زين
كلو زيدان اهلا بك هل بالفعل هناك حديث
يدور فيها شارع التركي وفي اروقه سياسه
التركيه عن حجم هذه العمليه ما القراءه
الاوليه
نعم عادل لا شك ان اتصالات انقره ما
حلفائها لاسيما القوى الموجوده على الارض
ونتحدث هنا عن الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وروسيا تكثف تكثفت خلال الساعات الماضيه
والايام الماضيه هذا اليوم وزير الدفاع
التركي اتصل بنظره الروسي وكان هناك
محادثات حول الوضع في سوريا وايضا في
اوكرانيا طبعا الشق الاكبر او الجانب
الاكبر من المحادثات كان عن وضع في سوريا
حيث اعاد وزير الدفاع التركي التاكيد على
حق بلاده في رد الهجمات التي تاتي همم من
خارج الحدود في اشاره الى سوريا ايضا كان
هناك اتصال يوم امس بين رئيس هيئه الاركان
التركيه ونظيره الامريكي طبعا هذه
الاتصالات تاتي بعد التصريحات الرئيس
التركي يوم امس هو الذي اكد فيها بان
العمليه البريه ستكون في وقت يناسب انقره
همم وكان في تصريحات سابقه قال ان
العمليات الجويه ليست هي الا البدايه وان
عمل همم سيكون او اجتياح مر سيكون قريب
همم في سوريا طبعا الرئيس التركي والمصادر
التركيه تتحدث عن همم ثلاث مناطق للعمليه
العسكريه المحتمله ونتحدثنا عن مدينه
ترفعت في شريف حلب الشمالي ومنبج في ريف
حلب الشرقي وعين العرب ايضا في ريف حلب
الشرقي طبعا مصادر العربيه اكدت لنا قبل
قليل
اجتماع بين قيادات عسكريه مع قيادات من
الفصائل المعارضه السوريه المدعومه من
انقره على الحدود التركيه السوريه هذا
الاجتماع كان مساء هذا اليوم همم طبعا حتى
الان لم تكشف همم المصادر او لم نعلم حتى
الان تفاصيل الاجتماع لكن توقيت الاجتماع
في ظل تصاعد الحديث اكثر عن همم العمل
العسكري البري طبعا هذا همم او التهديدات
التركيه باشتياح بدات منذ مايو ايجار
الماضيه عندما بدا الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان يتحدث عن عمليه
ثلاث محاور
ومنبج وعين العرب تجدد هذا الحديث ايضا
والتهديدات بعد الهجوم الذي شهدته مدينه
اسطنبول همم قبل حوالي 10 ايام في شارع
الاستقلال واتهمت فيه الحكومه التركيه حزب
العمال الكردستاني ومن تصفهم بالفرع
السوري لحزب العمال الكردستاني اي وحدات
حمايه الشعب همم الكرديه بالمسؤوليه عن
هذا الهجوم لذلك بدات عمليه جويه او ضربات
جويه باسم همم السيف المخلب بيوم الاحد
الماضي وما زالت التصريحات التركيه تتحدث
عن عمل بري لكن همم كل المراقبين هنا
يعتقدون ان العمل العسكري همم بهذه همم
بالحديث التركي وتصور التركي يجب ان يكون
بالتنسيق مع واشنطن وماسكو وننتظر نتائج
هذه الاتصالات
شكرا جزيلا
العسل العربيه من اسطنبول زيدان كلوب
[موسيقى]
ايظن افاد مراسل العربيه ان وابدا
الامريكيه نلتقي اليوم في اليوم قيادات
بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه وبحث وقفا
الهجمات التركيه واوضح المراسله ان منسق
مجلس الامن القوميه الامريكيه للشرق
الاوسط بريتماكو
جورج هو من يقود جهود التهديئه بين قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه وتركيا
رغم هذا اللقاء الذي يبحث او وقف الهجمات
التركيه الا ان الاكراد يعتبرون ان الموقف
الامريكي لا يزال خجلا وربما محايد نوعا
ما اذا اتهم القياديه في قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه بسام صقر اتهم الولايات
المتحده انها باعت الاكراد صقر اضاف
لصحيفه الشرق الاوسط ان قصد تخشى ان يتكرر
ما حدث عام 2019 في اشاره الى الاتفاقيه
التي وقعت مع اداره الرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب
وراقتي داعش في قوله ان العمليه البريه
التركيه التي لا يبدو ان واشنطن بصدد
الاعتراض عليها لم تضعف داعش بل ستقاميه
طب انا الاكراد الى حد ما اذا اكد المبعوث
الروسي الخاص الى سوريا الى فرنسا
تمتنع عن شم هجوم بريه على سوريا مشيرا
الى ان بلاده من خلال وزاره الدفاع تقوم
باقناع على اطراف بضروره ضبط النفس
والابتعاد عن التسعيد فيما حذرته وزاره
الخارجيه الروسيه بان العمليه البريه
التركيه ستزيد التوتر ونشاط المسلحين في
المنطقه
منا بخوم الالمانيه معنا نواف خليل مدير
المركز الكرديه للدراسات اهلا بك سيد نواف
يعني بين هذا الموقف
للاكراد من الولايات المتحده وبين محاوله
اطمئنه الروسيه لهم من ان تركيا هذه
العمليه اين يقفون تحديدا
مساء الخير لكم شادي العربيه اين مكانه
فقط ملاحظه صغيره
فقط
والعربي بقيه المكونات القديمه
[موسيقى]
التي تزود المنطقه كلها
همم الغاز يعني منطقه تضم الملايين البشر
ما علاقه الادعاء التركيه التي لا اساس
لها من اصحاب بهذا الاستهداف الوحشي
للبنيه التحتيه فيما يتعلق بالعلاقه مع
الولايات المتحده ليست لدى العرب ولا احد
في المنطقه
[موسيقى]
الولايات المتحده تدخلت في الحرب ضد داعش
في كوباني
وشركاهم الذين تمكنوا من تحقيق النصر على
داعش خلال عده اعوام ولا تزال الحرب
لكن الحرب
بامريكا تكون في المنطقه لكن الان بعد
الحرب في اوكرانيا والصراع الغربي
الروسي اذا الجهاز التعبير على استماره
تركيا هو ما ينفذ منه الرئيس التركي لا
الهجوم على المنطقه يعني تحت ذراء شده
يعني المثل هذا توقف على العمليه
الارهابيه التي حدثت في اسطنبول عشرات
مرات بالمئات المرات العربيه متى سيكون
الهجوم على المنطقه الشماليه الشرقيه
في نفس الوقت ايران ايضا باتت تستغل هذه
الروضاه وتضرب في اقليم كردستان العراق
والجانب الامريكان هناك ايضا يتفرجون طيب
ما هو اليوم الولايات المتحده لديها مصالح
مع تركيا الروس ايضا لديهم صالح مع تركيا
الكل يخطب مده تركيا ولكن هذه العمليه
يبدو انها ستكون في ديسمبر ولا احد يعرف
حجم او الى اين ستصل هذه العمليه وحجمها
الهدف الاست
راتي كوباني 19
2012 تدمير الاداره الذاتيه يعني حتى
حينما كانت داعش على الحدود مع تركيا منذ
2013 الى 2016 لن تحرك ساكنه على الطاقه
يعني ثلاثه سنوات كانت تركيا تتفرج على
داعش الان ااه ايضا جاء يعني ظروف تركيا
تحاول ان تهاجم لكن الذي يمنع او الذي
يدفع الجانب الامريكي للتحرش بمنع تركيا
من الجمعه الى المنطقه وجود اكثر من
10,000 داعش يسجون قوات سوريا
الاف ايه في مخيم همم
النساء والرجال ايضا في مخيم الهون هو
الاخطر على وجه الارض الجانب الروسي ايضا
يحاول من زاويه الضغط من خلال التحديثات
تركي الضغط على الادارسه
تسير المنطقه لنظام السوري وهو ما لم يحصل
شكرا جزيلا يا سيدنا نواف خليل المدير
المركز الكردي للدراسه
[موسيقى]
ما تكلمت عنه الصحف الغربيه في الايام
القليله الماضيه في ما يخص حزمه عقوبات
جديده ضد روسيا ظهر الى العالم رئيسه
المفوضيه الاوروبيه ارسلها فون دير لاينك
اكدت ان الاتحاد الاوروبي يعدو حزمه تاسعه
من العقوبات ضد روسيا ردا على هجومها على
اوكرانيا مشيره الى ان الاتحاد يعمل جاهدا
على استهداف في روسيا في المجالات التي
تؤلمها لتفويض قدرتها على مواصله الحرب
على اوكرانيا
نعمل بجد لضرب روسيا حيث من المؤلم زياده
حده قدرتها على شن حرب على اوكرانيا
وبامكانيه الاعلان اليوم باننا نعمل باسرع
ما يمكن للفرد حزمه تسع من العقوبات وانا
واثقه من ان المفوضيه ستوافق ايضا على
اقرار حد اقصى لسعر النفط الروسي عالميا
نحن ومع مجموعه السبع وشركاء رئيسيين
اخرين للنهدا حتى تتغلب اوكرانيا على بوتن
وحربه الهمجيه وغير القانونيه
ياتي هدفي ما اعلنت المجر فشل وزراء
الطاقه في الاتحاد الاوروبي في التوافق
على وضعه سقف لاسعار الغاز وتجيل
المناقشات الى شهر ديسمبر المقبل وقال
وزير الخارجيه المجاريه عقبه اجتماعا في
بروكسل لان العديده ان العديده من وزراء
الطاقه الاوروبيه وضعوا ملاحظات حول مقترح
المفوضيه الاوروبيه بشان سقف اسعار الغاز
وقرروا الاستمرار في مناقشه هذه الملاحظات
والاجتماع مجددا في ديسمبر
ومع تعلي الاصوات خلف الكواليس الدوليه
بضروره وضعي حد للقتال الروسي الاوكراني
والجلوس الى طاوله المفاوضات يبدو الا
مستجيب كيف اكدت على لساني مستشار مدير
المكتب الرئيسي الاوكراني ان تلك الدعوات
مجرد اوهام وفي تغريده على حسابه على
تويتر شدد انه لا يمكن ان تنتهي الحرب بحل
الوسط على حساب الاراضي الاخرانيه وحياته
الاوكرانيه في المقابله الروسي ايضا نائب
وزير
الخارجيه اتصالات الرفيعه المستوى مع
الولايات المتحده رغم ان الحوار يجري عبر
القنوات الدبلوماسيه مشيرا الى ان مبادره
الاتصال يجب ان تاتي من الولايات المتحده
لانها هي من قاطع روسيا وقامت من جانب
واحد بتقليص العمل في عدد من المجالات على
حد
قوله
[موسيقى]
مع تبدد الامل بمحدثات سلا من قريبه لا
تبشر الاوضاع الميدانيه على الارض بحال
افضل لي تراجع القوات الروسيه في الاونه
الاخيره عبر مسؤولون امريكيون من لجوء
موسكو لاستخدام الاسلحه الكيماويه لتعويض
الخسائر
ودبابات ومسيرات لم تكن وقودا كافيا
لاشعال الوضع في الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا تلويح ومخاوف من استخدام السلاح
النووي سيطرت على اجواء الحرب تبعتها
اتهامات المتبادله بين الطرفين باستخدام
القنبله القذره ثم كانت المسيارات
الايرانيه التي خدمت القوات الروسيه فيها
هجماتها على اوكرانيا والان يلقى الحديث
الى اسلحه محرمه دوليا
في ظل الخسائر والتراجع الروسي في
اوكرانيا تتوقع الولايات المتحده ان تلجا
موسكو الى الاسلحه الكيماويه اذا استمر
تراجعها بحسب مجله بوليتكو والتي نسبت
المعلومات الى مسؤولين امريكيين
مقابل الشكوك الامريكيه جددت موسكوتها
مكيف باجراء تجارب بيولوجيه عسكريه تحت
اشراف امريكيه مؤكده انها ستقدم تفاصيل
تلك التجارب التي اعلنت عنها في مارس
الماضي بالرغم من نفي واشنطن وكيف
[موسيقى]
شتاء طويل سيمر على طرفي الحرب ليصبح تقدم
الاسلحه التقليديه على الارض صعبا ويفتح
احتمال تحولها الى حرب غير تقليديه قد
يتجاوز اثرها وكوارثها حدود البلدين الى
عمر العربيه
[موسيقى]
انتقادات واسعه في اوروبا فتحت الباب على
اعاده النظر بالعلاقات الاوروبيه الصينيه
رئيس المجلس الاوروبيه شارل ميشيل اعلن عن
عزمه اجراء زياره الحسين على الاسبوع
المقبل يلتقي خلالها الرئيس الصيني فيجن
اما بالنسبه لجدول الاعمال افاد ميشيل في
تغريده له ان المباحثات ستركز على
التحديات الدوليه وقضايا داخل الاهتمام
مشترك على واقع البيئه والسياسيه
والاقتصاديه المتوفره
تاتي هذه الزياره في ظل خلافات بين عواصم
الاتحاد الاوروبيه بشان كيفيه التعامل مع
ملف العلاقات مع الصين خصوصا القلق من دعم
بكين لروسيا واسجل له الصين الحقوقي
والتهديدات لتايوان والضغوط التجاريه على
عدد من بلدان الاتحاد الاوروبي هنا يكمن
التحدي لشرم ميشيل خلال زيارته في الحفاظ
على نهج وسط بين دول اوروبيه لديها مصالح
اقتصاديه قويه مع الصين بينما تعرض الدول
الاخرى اي تقارب معها بيل وتقيم علاقات مع
تايوان يحاول ميشيل المحافظه على نهج وسطي
بين المانيا التي لديها مصالح اقتصاديه
واسعه مع الصين من جهه واعضاء في الاتحاد
الاوروبيانيا التي اثارت حفيظه بكين عبر
اقامه علاقات مع تايوان من جهه اخرى
في اخبار الساعه لدينا ايضا
من تحت انقاذ الزلزاليه اندونيسيا نجاه
الطفل المعجزه
[موسيقى]
لهم ماسكه على شركه تويتر الى تاجيج
اصطدام الحزبي بين
الديمقراطيين والجمهوريين في واشنطن وهو
عمرو يسلط الضوء على اهميه مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي في السياسه الداخليه
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعيه تعد احد مظاهر
التفاعل في اطار ثوره التكنولوجيا لكنها
تلعب دورا ايضا في عالم السياسه منصه
تويتر دليل واضح
[موسيقى]
على تويتر
لكن في الولايات المتحده كانت تاثير
امتلاك ماسك لتويتر اعمق على الصعيد
السياسي اجج الصدامه الحزبي في واشنطن بين
الحزبين الديمقراطي والجمهوري مع اختلاف
نقاط التركيز بينهما
[موسيقى]
ايران مصر
الاخيره ويقول بعض الديمقراطيين انها قد
تعرض قدره المنصه على تامين البيانات
الشخصيه لمستخدمها
[موسيقى]
اسف اسف
رئيسه مجلس النواب المحتمل العام المقبل
فيقولون ان الديمقراطيين يلاحقون ماسك
بسبب استعداده لمنح المحافظين صوتا على
المنصه ورد بان الانتقادات الديمقراطيه هي
محاوله مستتره للقضاء على الاصوات
المحافظه على الموقع وحجم معتبروه حريه
التعبير
لحريه التعبير وتهديد مباشر لحزب
الديمقراطي وحلفائه في وسائل الاعلام
القديمه بينما يهاجم الديمقراطيون اي جهد
لاعطاء الامريكيين صوتا اقوى سيكون
الجمهوريون يقضين ضد التواطئ بين شركات
التكنولوجيا الكبرى وهذه الاداره
صحيفه وول ستريت جورنال حذرت من انه
اصطدام قد ينذر بمزيد من الاستقطاب حول
الانترنت ودوري الحكومه في تنظيمه تصاعدات
في السنوات الاخيره دعوات للكونجرس لتحسين
حمايه الخصوصيه وتخفيف هيمنه شركات
التكنولوجيا العملاقه عبر تحديث القانون
الذي يحميها من المسؤوليه عن محتوى الطرف
الثالث
اهلا انا مطار برلين برغر انه اغلق مدارج
الاقلاعي والهبوط بعد ان دخلها عده اشخاص
بشكل غير قانوني بينما اعلن التاج جماعه
معنيه بمكافحه تغير المناخ ان نشطائها
اوسخوا انفسهم بالمدرج وخرج جماعه الجيل
الاخير البيئيه
لانشاط النشاط دعوه الناس الى التوقف عن
السفر جوا كما طلبه الحكومه بالتوقف عن
دعم هذا النوع من السفر
[موسيقى]
من كان له عمر لا تقتله شده طفل كتب له ان
يبقى على قيد الحياه بعد ان بقي يومين
عالقا تحت انقاذ الزلزال جزيره قهوه في
اندونيسيا الزلزال وقع قرب مدينه سيايغو
غرب الجزيره واودى بحياتي مالا يقل عن 271
شخصا في شريط الفيديو الذي نشرته سلطات
المنطقه
ظهر عنصر الانقاذ مبتسما وهو يحمل الصبي
بينما يركض بعنصر اخر خلفهما ليمسك بيد
الطفل ابتسامه من بين الركام
روان
[موسيقى]
انتهاكات النظام الايراني ضد المحتاجين
تحت المجهر تشكيله لجنه الامميه للتحقيق
والمحاسبه
مفاجاه المونديال مستمره البرتغال تجتاز
غانا بصعوبه ولا عيون على نتائج البرازيل
او نتيجه البرازيل وصربيا 2-0 حتى الان
رغم اللقاء الامريكي بقصد للتهديئه
الاكرادي يشعرون بالخضلان وتركيا تواصلها
هجماتها شمال سوريا
بعد يا زياره شولت المثيره للجدل لبكين
رئيس المجلس الاوروبي يحمل وجندتهم حساسه
للصين الاسبوع المقبل
في امان الله
[موسيقى]